quelle est la plus grosse connerie que
fais tu dans ta vie je sais pas j'ai pas
mal ma plus grosse
j'en sais rien quand il était marié est
ce que tu penses que tu a tout fait pour
garder ton mari ouais ouais si c'était à
refaire
qu'est-ce que tu ne le ferai pas
qu'est-ce que je referai pas depuis le
début de ma vie je crois que je serais
allé voir le en fait le premier garçon
dont j'étais vraiment amoureuse et que
je serais allé lui montrer mon amour
sans orgueil son me drapé dans un
orgueil et lapointe et je suis allé lui
dire que je l'aimais vraiment et je
l'aurai pas laisser partie voilà
pourquoi tout l'a pas fait parce qu'il
est mort maintenant que j'ai pas eu le
temps et j'ai été congelé pas face à
tanger attendu et puis bon il ya il ya
eu ça je crois que c'était lui et
l'homme de ta vie non je pense je pense
pas sinon resteraient pas - ou alors je
serais morte aussi non j'ai enfin en
tous les cas j'espère pas parce que
c'est dans ce cas là ma vie est foutue
et puis si je pensais vraiment que ça
avait été l'homme de ma vie je pense pas
je vous serais mariée couple tu es
amoureuse en ce moment
quand on voit en photo dans les journaux
avec un acteur américain est également
reconnue et pourquoi pas ce que parce
que parce qu'on va trouver ma vie privée
on l'a jetée en pâture au public alors
que j'étais pas d'accord je suis
d'accord de de donner un certain un
certain nombre de choses qui
m'appartiennent mais quand on vient de
les voler je suis pas d'accord donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas envie de
répondre à cette question
cette histoire là j'ai envie de la
préserver et j'ai pas envie qu'on vient
de me l'a gâché avec des photos des cdd
des photos de paparazzi et des choses
comme ça toi qui vas être mariée mais
j'espère à 21 ans ça dommage de me dire
voilà ma fille c'est terminé pour toi tu
as plus tard marié oui j'espère que je
me remarier il doit comme hovington
non maintenant je me vois sereine avec
toute ma famille autour de moi dans une
dans une maison dans un dans un endroit
où je me sens bien avec avec des rires
partout je dois une baguette magique tu
ferais quoi comme métier j'avais une
baguette magique chanteuse de hard rock
un bon et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de 1h10 tube abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu